today's show will be all about sex
hedonism and free love because I've got
a month left of bachelorhood and I need
tips on how to really live it up and
speaking of hippie communes today is May
Day which is celebrated by pagans and
communists alike
lucky for us in the United States we
celebrate a very different holiday today
which we'll get to in this day in
history
finally on cults and culture new studies
reveal an epidemic of hatred and
loneliness in America but first we have
Bridget fantasy in studio writes for The
Federalist and playboy and spent time in
the very sex cult featured in wild wild
country I'm Michael Knowles and this is
the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
a lot to get to today sex communes cults
bad culture why Americans are lonely and
they hate each other we have a little
bit of hope at the end but I want to get
straight to the sex so let's very
quickly you know speaking of these two
sort of relate I won't go too into it we
have to thank one of my favorite
sponsors
wink wink is a wonderful sponsor because
wink sends me wine and that puts them
right at the top of the heap just for
that a wink is a wonderful product you
have to check it out right now
so let me give you a task pick out a
wine that you're going to love but
here's a catch you haven't had it before
how do you do that because what I do is
I go to the liquor store the wine store
and I see a gazillion wines and I know
absolutely nothing whatsoever about it
and then I spend a lot of money and I
don't love it or sometimes I miss those
great wines that aren't that expensive
and they're perfect for me wink solves
all of these problems winc wink it makes
it easy to discover great wine this is a
very important thing life is too short
for bad wine only drink great wine and
don't bankrupt yourself while you're
doing it
you can get wonderful wonderful deals on
wine I want winks wine experts select
wines match to your taste personalized
for you shipped right to your door
starting at just $13 per bottle forget
the two buck chuck fellas this is a this
is 2018 treat yourself white right right
with wine the life is too short there is
nothing like coming home to a delicious
box of wink wine all these beautiful
bottles arrayed out selected just for
you and what you do is you go on you
take the palette profile quiz so usually
for me they say do you like wine I say
yeah no how do you like it wet and then
they send it to me but they have really
specific questions that can tell you a
lot about your palates so you know how
do you take your coffee
do you like salt do you like citrus you
know that kind of thing each month wink
sends you new delicious wines curated to
your taste such as the insanely popular
summer water rose a listen fellas don't
be too proud to have a little rose a
rose a makes the day shipping is covered
there are no membership fees you can
skip any month you can cancel anytime
there is no reason not to try this up
your wine game you have to do it if you
don't like a bottle they send you
they'll just replace it with a bottle
you'll love no questions asked
discover great wine today go to try wink
dot-com / Knowles ko wles like jay-z's
wife you will get $20 off your first
shipment I am I'm giving you a wonderful
gift folks don't turn it down t ry winc
comm / knowles KO wles $20 off try wink
calm / knowles okay we've got to get
right into this i want to jump right
into the sex cults if you haven't seen
this i think this is the biggest show on
netflix right now wild wild country it's
about the Rajneesh e cult that was in
oregon and they took over a city
basically and they all wore orange or
red and had a lot of sex and followed
this crazy Indian guy if you haven't
seen it here's just a little bit of the
trailer everybody felt they were there
at the beginning of the great experiment
like we were the chosen people a
prominent Indian guru and his followers
bought it
but once agenda was simply to raise the
consciousness of humanity that was his
goal they're run by satanic power there
is talk of vigilantes who may seek
revenge on the rajneeshees
I didn't take measures to protect their
community to disarm this cults army now
we would poison a whole town
the Rajneesh they were facing
immigration fraud smuggling the Rajesh's
came this close to murdering a
presidential appointee there's darkness
in all of us
doesn't make you a bad person that
menacing laugh at the end that is the
Raj Nishi cult and coincidentally you
might have seen bridge at fantasy you
might have read her writing on the
federalists or playboy.com which I only
read for the articles you might have
seen her there I think bridget is
actually the only person that writes for
both the Federalists and playboy.com
before her was just Bill Buckley
coincidentally Bridget actually spent
about a month on a Rajneesh e sex cult
in Australia not the one in Oregon but
they have these all over the world and
she spent it on one in Australia we're
joined right now by Bridget feda see
Bridget thank you for being here thank
you see you we you know I love your
writing thank you coincidentally you
happen to experience probably the
biggest TV phenomenon in person up close
maybe up a little too close I didn't
think I would ask this question on the
Michael Nolt show what made you join a
sex cult I was traveling I I had booked
a one-way ticket and just trout we
wanted to put a backpack on and travel
and I went with this guy that I met in
Sydney we went up to the coast and it
was their holidays and he assured me
that there would be a place to stay in
Byron Bay and I got there and there was
nowhere to stay and he was having a
boy's weekend so he being not a
gentleman it's basically like you're on
your own girl I just met Bridget I don't
know if that's not like just being not a
gentleman like if I'm not a gentleman I
don't pick up the tab at dinner or
something but I've never ditched my date
for a sex cult and so I ended up looking
on woofing I was subscribed all these
different sites like couchsurfing and
woofing and I looked on woofing and they
had an ad for it was just like a
spiritual retreat is what they called it
whooping is that's the organic floor I
think is worldwide organic farming if
you're traveling on a budget it's a
great way to go around and
work four hours a day for somebody on a
farm and then you can go do whatever you
want if your your it's a good way to get
around the world and places like Chile
and New Zealand in particular and
Australia and then I was like oh
spiritual retreat that sounds you know
harmless enough and I went and they they
said oh there's a car in town right now
getting supplies we can pick you up
today and I said perfect right and then
they showed up and they were all in
white with beads and crazy eyes and did
they they all had crazy eyes they
definitely had that that like the look
we're just I don't know if it is just
the brainwashing that happens that your
eyes it's like disconnected a little bit
and they showed up and I got in the car
and you know at some point I'm I have a
very storied past and I sometimes do
things I'm a writer and sometimes I make
decisions because I'm like oh this'll be
cool story and who knows but then I
realize you know I'm taking my life in
my own hands right it might be dangerous
and I ended up in the car and the guy
was driving like a maniac really
aggressively through all these windy
back roads and I was like wow I I might
never see my family or friends again I
could just disappear no one knew where I
was I mean it was reckless you're in the
middle of Australia you're then you
don't have communication tools right not
really I had you know a little like flip
phone that I bought when I started
traveling but it wasn't you know this
was before it there I don't even think
air B&B was a thing yet it wasn't too
long ago it was 2012 but it wasn't like
it is now now you get there because I've
seen the show the show is really good
wild wild country you could check it out
how similar is it how what is this the
Australian version like it wasn't I mean
the scenes that you see that are really
graphic it was funny because I walked
into the living room and my roommate was
watching it and she and I was like hey
I've done that and it
I'm doing dynamic meditation and she was
like of course you have Bridget what are
you talking about this is a documentary
I was like no I was on an ashram the
dead all this stuff what is this and
then she was timing like oh yeah this is
the guy who started he's the guy that
had the hole it was the whatever that
what we practiced on the ashram yeah
it was his we listened to his tapes and
we did the dynamic meditation which is a
meditation that he invented and it's um
it wasn't like as raw and aggressive and
naked and kind of crazy I didn't want to
pry but yeah I wanted to know it on all
of these other ashrams that are still in
existence today are they all having
weird bizarre sitar music tantric sex
yes and no so most ashrams Osho kind of
he rejected the traditional ashram
aesthetic and he was very he said it's
not all about just denial it's about
embracing he had this whole thing called
Zorba the Buddha where you can you can
meditate but you can also drink and be
wild and crazy and have sex and you
don't have to renounce all these things
to be spiritual in fact spirituality and
sexuality are linked you know you can't
you can't really untangle them and
encourage polyamory and all of this kind
of partner swapping and and yeah I I
think that most ashrams that you go to
come from a strict lineage I went to
another one in news in New Zealand and
it was you know the golden silence from
8:00 until 8:00 and kirtan in the
morning but it was with meditation and
it was very strict and you it was the
complete opposite so I think those that
Osho Ashram czar their own little
culture know who is running this thing
in Australia so it's not the Bhagwan
Indian guy that lived in Oregon who's
the guy in Australia I it was a guy
named samaya but it was I think he was
an Italian trust fund because that's
comfortable now
that note to self when Ben fires you
yeah okay go let's see man it seems like
a pretty good gig way I like how you can
kind of just go retreat and then come
and everyone's like oh yeah but most of
the time you just kind of spend alone I
think he just watch TV I don't know what
he was doing it's less work if you can
get it the bhagwan spent a lot of time
alone and he was like he was isolated a
lot
did you so I'm wondering how this
Italian guy did it
is there a brainwashing that goes on yes
it's insidious and subtle and it's it's
not ever it's like my brain is kind of
wash resistant I think I had a lot of
experiences leading up to that that made
me very skeptical of anybody using
sexuality to be spiritual which we won't
get into what but I did have that's
where after the break yeah that's for
the subscribers oh I had an immunity to
that kind of tactic but I did I can see
how you get broken down it's really
erratic the the exercises that Osho had
you do or in this case at this ashram
our our guru it's you vastly between
emotions really rapidly so if you and I
were doing an exercise I would be its
first it's like gibberish and then
they'd ding a bell and then you start
laughing like a crazy person like and
then it sounds like acting class it is
I'm making a joke but that is true they
do this in acting that's another one of
the immunities that I was like oh it's
like improv I can do this and then you
just start but then it dings about and
then you started screaming each other
and just by and you see that on the
thing there's just kind of and it makes
you crazy
it definitely destabilizes your your
emotional center that sounds like
explains every actor that I've ever had
it does remind me trees you're
describing la yeah that's right yeah I
don't I don't you didn't have to go to
Australia you know it's a lie la is a
weird sex cult isn't it
it is I think so I think there's a nurse
so many homes in LA there are I mean
I've many people who have joined cults
in LA I mean Scientology a big one but
there's um one of the other another
investigative piece that I did was on
orgasmic meditation and as I did the
piece and everybody kind of any
journalist who had written about it kind
of drank the kool-aid and I was like my
the only one who thinks this is kind of
weird and I went and my therapist was
like be careful bridge I was like this
can we kind of triggering just be
careful and they didn't do I was calling
a dental club because we do blanket
diddle club we'll see we'll fix it in
post
yeah and yeah it's a it's a whole thing
about it being in the home of the and as
I afterward the piece I got emails from
therapists up in San Francisco which is
where this thing started of course then
they were saying that they were so glad
that I can't
I was critical of it because they have
clients who are suffering and nobody I
mean there really should be like a
full-blown investigative report about
this it sounds exhausting it or orgasmic
meditation says it's sex Ossining if you
will but that's that's very tiring and
you keep that up oh hi Joe I was out
after the first flake intro now I'm
gonna avoid making all of the jokes or
you know because it's a family show but
they're all there's a lot to say this
reminds me of the famous triptych by
Hieronymus Bosch the Garden of Earthly
Delights where you know as famous
triptych where it's the paradise and
it's beautiful and then everyone's kind
of having these sensual pleasures and
then it is hell on earth yeah it was
just your revelation hell you know you
you write in your piece about this
excellent piece of mell magazine you're
right where we just hedonists following
our bliss or was there something evil or
looking behind it all which is it and
what's the difference well I think the
road to hell is you anything can be
perverted I think you can go in with
good intentions of being spiritual and
wanting to connect just something higher
and I think that's why so many people
end up in India or on these pilgrimages
they're not shrooms you're not you're
not living the dream and like okay I'm
gonna go check out and and you know just
go off the grid I think there's an
internal sense of restlessness or
longing for a feeling of connection to
something bigger so it would be very
easy to manipulate that for money or
power or prestige or any of these things
and I think that you find these people
in myself I can only speak for myself I
kind of turned the other cheek to a lot
of the stuff that was going on because I
was just enjoying myself and ultimately
on holiday and new I was new I was
leaving
there were moments where I didn't want
to leave because it was nice being there
is something very natural about living
that way that's quite simple so simple
you have no decisions to make because
some swarthy little Indian millionaire
makes them for you and it's a there's a
nice routine and you're not wasting you
know sometimes I like be pumping gas or
I'll be I'll be throwing a Starbucks cup
away and I'm like this is it sustainable
you know there's a I'll go into Costco
and it's like everything in here is
gonna end up in a landfill oh yeah
coming you know how is this the thing
that's how I meditate actually as I just
pour fossil fuels on the ground I think
ah now I'm at peace um
yeah yeah right so there is something
kind of it's like a bit of a relief and
I found that it was a relief although I
missed all those earthly pleasures and
and I wonder you because you write about
this in the mail piece you say that you
missed civilization yeah you met you
really liked the kind of simple
sensuality spirituality some farming or
whatever but that you also missed like
booze and cochran drugs nice food and
meat and steak yeah you eventually come
back to civilization is it in your line
about hedonism is it just the natural
end of hedonism is this cultish ness it
gives itself over to coalition us and
what does that boundary like I think it
does I don't know I don't know where you
where you go and you know where we I
don't know where you end up at the end
of hedonism other than searching hmm for
something because it is so I know where
you go it's all la it is you come to LA
where you're already here and it's you
know all of these cults pop up in the
most hedonistic cities in America and I
think it's because they're all these
people in LA and you'll say yeah well
I'm a Catholic say oh you believe in
that crazy superstition that's
ridiculous
hold on I just have to I have to move
around my chakras because Mercury's in
retrograde I can't believe you believe
in that crazy Catholic Church and it
often it's the people who are not
religious we're very hedonistic they're
the most superstitious people on earth
oh I mean I feel this way about atheism
even it's the dogma of atheism like you
guys really spend a lot of time telling
me preaching your atheistic values it
feels if that fit feels the same way to
me I I think we all want something to
believe as humans because it's very
confusing being human and I don't know
much I'm not that smart
I do know a lot about the human
condition from my own experience and the
human condition I think is very
confusing because there's this sense of
order the Sun rises it sets there are
seasons and yet there's
this chaos and so that chaos you want to
make it make sense you that is the
essential I mean Jordan Peterson just
sold a gazillion books on this the
essential human motive is to make order
out of chaos and to and to pursue the
good to pursue the virtue so I wonder
you know culture and cult come from the
same word they've to cultivate right
they come from both derived from the
same thing which is worse a whacky
Indian sex cult in Australia or our
modern decadent materialistic culture
broadly in the West ooh and it's
interesting because there isn't much
difference from the experience I had in
at that ashram and working up on a farm
in Oregon there's there's a lot of
overlap the polyamorous and even in LA
the culture here and it leads all which
is worse and whack some say the world
will end in fire some say in ice from
what I've tasted of desire you know
there are a lot of everyone's being
exploited so whether you're exploited
for your breath work down here or you
are exploited for money on this ashram
or or your your psychology is I think
the dangerous thing that happens in
places like ashrams as opposed to being
in civilization is it your brain breaks
in those places and I definitely had
friends that I'm still in touch with
whose brains are a little bit broken
from the ashram they can't really exist
in civilization and they don't really
have a desire to because they haven't
they lost their that socialization
they they're incapable of like the noise
they the noise is too much and the chaos
and the capitalism and well you you talk
about it explicitly in one moment in the
piece you say they tried to give you a
new name they did that's that's the
moment where you thought this is getting
pretty weird Sarita yes of course
premiere yeah yeah the river of love
they gave you this new name is this is
just a cynical tactic to break your
individual app they do a lot of that and
do you think that that I I guess did
again one of the differences it's
targeted breaking in an ashram whereas
here maybe it's more insidious like la
just wears you down slowly and traffic
and absolutely unsatisfied yeah but
there it's very much forget who you are
the outside world doesn't matter
the your gonna disconnect from your
family they don't need to hear from you
you're isolated so there's a big
difference between any any situation
whether it's Scientology or the ashram
or anything where it's isolating you
from your friends and family and people
that love you and know you that's even
real let you see it in relationships
right I mean I think Drew and I were
joking he's like can't I just be a cult
of one and I was like I think that's
marriage you're the one I always refer
to drew Clavin is the Bhagwan you know
marriage is like a cult of do that Wow
that you know you've really taken me
full circle here Brigitte initially I
just wanted to dive into a weird sexy
Sittard laid an ashram but now you've
really made me I can be my own Italian
coffee I don't need to go to Australia
to do that I'll do it right in my own
marriage you can do it right in your own
house there's so much more I want to
talk to you about but we have to wear
out I've got to get out of here I want
to talk to you oh there's so much okay
we'll just have to have you back okay
Bridget thank you pre pre me prom I'm
sorry Prem II Prem II thank you for
being here where can people find you oh
um twitter is the best I mind all the
socials but at Bridget fantasy as where
I'm on I live on Twitter at Bridget
fantasy don't we all I know it makes it
I want to throw it and go follow the
baggage I took it off my phone though
that's a good that's a good first step
now that I have this mug I will never be
working Holly you're done you've been
Kanye the Crips are gonna put a hit out
on you actually that's what happens
you're not gonna leave the Crips man
there's Kanye long before Kanye that Wow
well well hopefully you'll you'll be
able to get some good Trump tweets out
of that hopefully you can avoid the
Crips in the meantime Bridget fantasy go
find her on Twitter and read all of
stuff at the federalists or you know
playboy is not a bad website to visit a
royal mell magazine writes rights
everywhere and all right well see so
thank you so much Richard okay we've got
to get and talk a little bit about the
culture because you know we're talking
about weird sex cults and now we can
talk about our weird culture which is
absolutely in the gutter there's some
sad news that I want to get to about the
culture today before we sign off and get
to this day in history sad news about
the culture is that we all hate each
other
the Pew Research Center just has a
report out from last fall it's being
reported on now the report shows quote
among members of both parties the shares
with very unfavorable opinions of the
other party have more than doubled
they've increased by twenty eight full
percentage points since nineteen
ninety-four Republicans and Democrats
don't want to live in the same types of
communities anymore most of them admit
they have very few or no friends on the
other side of the aisle this is pretty
weird this is weird and I've noticed it
even in my brief stint on this earth the
politics has gotten much nastier and now
if I go to a dinner or something and I
say oh I'm Catholic or I don't know I'm
this or I have this belief or this
belief that is much more acceptable than
saying I'm a Republican or I voted for
Donald Trump that you cannot say it's a
very awkward you have to hide it you saw
this in voting patterns this is why the
polls weren't always so right at public
opinion polls about Trump support
because twenty percent of people don't
want to admit it eighteen percent of
people I think also know according to a
national survey in Salinas Ito's new
book show that people who voted for
Donald Trump
don't want to admit it to others because
they fear being ostracized if you're
losing their jobs their reputations or
their careers or friends or whatever
we know that lefties on Facebook or
three times more likely than
conservatives to unfriend people because
of their political views it's really
angry and bitter and I think it's
because the culture has gotten shallower
so every everything is just shouting and
yelling and I don't blame the two sides
equally for this there's this really
cool bio thing we say you know it's both
sides man no it actually is being driven
by the left
conservatives sometimes take their cues
or take the bait
but this is
being driven by the left it's being
driven by poisonous ideologies like
intersectionality which say hey forget
about our ideas forget about our reason
we're gonna gang up on this demographic
because we don't like this group of
people it's a really a wicked ideology
and also you see it in Jonathan heights
studies
Jonathan Hite published that famous
study a few years ago as reported on the
New York Times that conservatives
understand the left more or less but the
left doesn't understand conservatives
they view the world in only three value
categories and they value these things
are all a little malleable but the left
views the world in narrower value
categories and fewer value categories
than conservatives view the world so we
can understand that point of view but
for instance the left has trouble
understanding something like purity the
conservative value of purity they so
cares about purity what are you talking
about man I just want to live on my sex
cult or a my whole life or something
like that that's too bad usually the
loudest voices are the least
knowledgeable that tends to be the case
and you hear people say they say I'm
gonna shout my abortion I'm so proud I'm
gonna shout this or shout that I'm gonna
you know that girl when Donald Trump won
there was that video of her and she's
out there they say Donald Trump won the
election she goes no and she yells and
she's screams and because there's no
reasonable discourse if you're getting
angry and hot all the time you want to
unfriend people and scream and yell
usually that's a sign that you don't
understand what you're talking about
because I hear all sorts of crazy ideas
all day long I'd usually don't get that
flustered because I've heard them before
that that owes to a bad education system
that owes to a highly politicized
education system and a vicious shallow
highly politicized pop culture hopefully
that's turning around bridgett mentioned
that she got Kanye you know Brigitte
isn't some Edmund Burke II and
conservative with buttoned up wearing
tweed all the time certainly not on the
ashram but she got Kanye in that she's a
free thinker and these days if you're a
free thinker if you have independent
thought that puts you on the right I
don't think people signed up for that
but the left has moved so far to the
left
it just puts you on the right this ties
in with another sad
phenomenon that's happening in the
culture and that's loneliness there's an
epidemic right now of loneliness and
culture a new study from Cigna reveals
that loneliness is at epidemic levels in
America that this was a survey of 20,000
American adults aged 18 or older nearly
half of those adults report sometimes or
always feeling alone 46 percent or left
out 47 percent depending on how you
change the wording half of Americans
report being sometimes or always lonely
feeling alone one in four Americans more
than one in four 27% rarely or never
feel as though there are people who
really understand them but they have no
one who understands what they're going
through this total isolation for a
reporter of the country two in five
Americans 40% of the country sometimes
or always feel that their relationships
are not meaningful there are these
shallow relationships 43% and and that
they're isolated from others same
percentage 43% this I think is because
of the paltry view of friendship and
that comes because we've elevated sex so
we make sex the be-all and end-all you
don't have to you don't have to go to
Australia or Oregon or India for that to
happen that is pervasive around the
civilized world there's a hook-up
culture there it's the swipe right
culture it's one that elevates sex and
I'm not denigrating sex sex is a cool
thing man I'm all for it but it's not
the only type of relationship there are
plenty of other types of relationship
the Aristotle wrote about friendship
friendship is the important thing the
important relationship and it's love has
been described as two people looking at
one another lovers are two people who
look at one another and friends are two
people who stand next to one another and
look at the same thing they're pursuing
the same good there they're observing
the same good and that kind of deep
friendship I think is missing it's
missing in part because we're so afraid
to talk about anything
you're people are afraid to talk about
politics and religion don't talk about
politics or religion at the dinner table
folks that's that's what we're told it's
because if I say yes I voted for Bob
Dole in 96 they'll say you have vicious
bigoted voting for a moderate Republican
so we're not really willing to talk
about anything that matters
were only willing to talk about dinner
we said this is good chicken yeah no
how's the chickens good right that's all
people just talk about the food that
shallowness is is what makes people join
whacky cults to search for something
else because we know that's not
sufficient in life we want to have
meaningful relationships there was
another big study that came out and said
people hate small talk you don't need a
study to tell you that everybody hates
small talk
people say I want to go to this dinner
because I might have to have Yammer on
and babble about nothing and over
champagne or something that no one
people want to talk about things that
matter they want to think about things
that matter in the same survey from Pew
one in five people report that they
rarely or never feel close to people
there were they they feel like there are
people that they can talk to twenty
percent say they don't ever feel close
to people there aren't meaningful
relationships and it's because we have
humiliated the view of friendship we've
we've made it so shallow that it barely
exists and we've also destroyed the view
of relationships now you know Cole
Porter didn't sing let's do it let's be
in a relationship until one of us wants
to get out of it and then we'll swipe
right again right that's not of the song
goes let's fall in love let's give
ourselves to one another that view is is
on the decline that's a minority view
now or it's a repressed view and when
you bottle something up for too long
it's going to come out in weird ways
this survey also shows that Generation Z
so a lot of times when people talk about
the youths they talk about the
Millennials they say all the Millennials
do this the Millennials do that but
actually the Millennials are kind of old
now I'm a millennial Millennials are
late 20s early 30s Generation Z are the
people who are upwards of twenty
two-years-old Generation Z is reported
to be the loneliest generation of all
generations alive today they're the
loneliest this is bizarre because you
have the oldest generation alive they
should be the loneliest right because
all of their friends are dead or their
widowed or whatever no they actually are
doing relatively better than Generation
Z and a lot of people blame this on
social media use they cell it's because
your your heads are in your smartphones
you're not having meaningful
relationships that all might be true but
social media use according to this
survey is not a predictor of loneliness
that's bizarre the the loneliness Fair
is the same among
be social media users and light social
media users what this means is this is
partially what allows bizarre cults and
rituals to flourish this empty meanness
and shallowness of materialism and
abstracting things and saying oh well I
just I think of this person as an
abstraction he's a Republican he's a
Democrat he's a this cyst or a data
stand they think in only in terms of
abstractions so people are drawn to
these weird cultish activities people
love farming people love being with
people people love free love they love
the the tangible aspects of humanity
which in modern culture really doesn't
cherish as much but it's it's an
important aspect and everybody's got to
serve somebody they're you know when
when True Religion goes away people
become very superstitious they're you
can't avoid the metaphysical world so
you've got to channel these things into
healthy ways or else people are just
gonna get meaner and meaner and lonelier
and lonelier and I'm gonna have to move
to Australia and join the sex culture
okay we've got a lot more to talk about
because we have a we have a bright side
in this day in history but before we get
to that I'm sorry folks
we got to sign off I've also got some
pretty cool there's a good news to
announce I think Ben might have been
ousted on Twitter this morning starting
this Sunday May 6th join the one and
only Ben Shapiro in a brand new edition
of his podcast the Ben Shapiro show
Sunday special this is going to be
really cool we've been filming things
for this Ben will host a weekly in-depth
conversation with the nation's brightest
and best people on politics news culture
everything in between the first one is
with Jordan Peterson Jordan was by our
offices the other day it's gonna be
really really cool the best part is for
current Ben Shapiro show subscribers
it'll just show up in the feed it's just
part of the Ben Shapiro show it's the
new Sunday special if you don't
subscribe to the Ben Shapiro show I
don't believe that because you're
watching my show which films in his
broom closet but in any case you should
subscribe to Ben's show the Sunday
special is gonna be really really cool
this will be the premiere episode so I
think you'll really enjoy it in the
meantime you know daily wire is on Apple
news I just got my first iPhone I was on
all these other fake iPhones for the
last decade and it is so much better I'm
gonna join that cult that's a wonderful
cult but we're on Apple News
so subscribe to that and listen the last
pitch before I say goodbye to you who
aren't subscribing thank you for those
who subscribe you help us keep the
lights on you keep Kofi Fei in my cup go
to daily wire.com right now 10 bucks a
month $100 for an annual membership what
do you get you get me you get the end
replacement show you get the Ben Shapiro
show sometimes you get British fantasy
on my show you get the conversation you
get the Sunday special you get all this
stuff man but none of it matters this is
what matters right now we're gonna have
to get the [ __ ] addition of the leftist
year's tumblr the Crips are so sad that
Kanye got Kanye but he's tweeting out
Thomas soul quotes that Snoop Dogg's
cousin dem elimin ding dong or whatever
I didn't know what his name is
but he had told the Crips to put out a
hit on Kanye West so look that [ __ ]
edition of the left has tears that's
gonna be tasty and delicious because
those guys they put on a tough front you
know but really they they can cry look
real men can cry that's okay so make
sure you get your leftist ears tumblr or
it will imperil your life and your
health and I think my joking about the
Crips is probably imperiled my life and
my health go to daily wire.com we'll be
right back
okay we don't have a ton of time left
but happy law day happy law day
everybody I might not be the day that
you have been hearing about but it is
the 60th annual law day which is perhaps
the most American holiday
law day was proclaimed by Dwight
Eisenhower and Congress passed the
resolution for law day three years later
this law day was first proposed by the
American Bar Association in 1957 now I
know what you're thinking you're saying
Michael this isn't law day it's May Day
it's International Workers unite day
it's the Labor Day in all parts yeah
right no not an America baby
not in America the reason that we passed
law day was to suppress May Day which is
a pagan holiday that was later
appropriated by communists and became
the International Workers day so only in
America only in America could we take a
pagan communist holiday and say now
we're gonna make it about following
American laws we're gonna make it a day
to celebrate the Constitution and the
Declaration of Independence they define
law day when it passed as a national day
set aside to celebrate the rule of law
law day underscores how law and the
legal process have contributed to the
freedoms that all Americans share a
special day of celebration by the
American people in appreciation of their
liberties and rededication to the ideals
of equality and justice under law and I
think what went unsaid the subtext of
that was and as a big screw you to the
Communists and because May Day was
appropriated by the International
Workers day which was created formally
in 1904 had there had been allusions to
it before that by the second
international the communist organization
calling on all social democratic party
organizations and trade unions of all
countries to demonstrate energetically
on the 1st of May for the class demands
of the proletariat and for a universal
peace and what that is is fantasy
it's a fantasy that's that's the
difference between law day and
International Workers day is that the
universal peace on earth the Utopia
we're going back to the Garden of Eden
as long as I have to squish a few eggs
to make an omelet and kill millions of
people
to effect my utopian vision
but that's we're gonna have that's a
fantasy that's the devil talking and
America has law day that's the reality
actual liberties protected by actual
institutions in actual law May first had
been bubbling as a workers day since the
1880s so a lot of countries around the
world celebrate this as a labor day we
don't do it because we put Labor Day in
September and which is very lucky so we
don't get swept up in all this economy
worldwide celebration and then it wasn't
always a communist holiday May Day is a
pagan holiday May Day you hear you know
the Maypole May Day is a pagan
celebration of flora Lea which is the
the goddess of flowers
it's an ancient pagan holiday when
Europe became Christian May Day became
either secularized or Christianized so
you'd have these secular celebrations
the start of summer and you'd have these
Christian celebrations in Germany they
celebrate it as the feast day of Saint
Walburga and I I don't have any German
viewers anymore after I did the show
about how Germany is the worst country
in the world but for any of you who are
still out there happy Saint Wahlberg a
day by the 18th century this be turned
into devotions to Mary it's only one
letter off so May Day became a devotion
to Mary the Virgin Mary in recent years
neo-pagans have brought back the ancient
paganism of May Day they've they've
started to bring it back as paganism I
think is the fastest growing religion in
America
there's when people get hedonistic when
people pretend that there's no true
religion they start to worship all sorts
of superstitious things and that this is
a beautiful thing about America we take
pagan communist goop and we Americanize
it Christians have done this Christians
did this throughout the spread of
Western Christianity we would take pagan
traditions and we would baptize them and
make them Christian so sometimes
fundamentalists get angry they say the
Christmas tree was a pagan Germanic
ritual you say right but now it's a
Christmas tree that's a good that's an
improvement that's a step in the right
direction when you take a pagan thing
and you and you subdue it and transform
it into a Christian thing Americans do
this too we take holidays and we morph
them into American holidays we
Americanize them we don't negate we just
build and trans
form them we build them up and we
transform them that's what we have to do
in the culture because if we don't do
that if we allow if we ignore the
popular culture then we're gonna get run
over by it we're gonna get hit by a bus
this is why some people are upset about
Kanye West they say we shouldn't say
nice things about Kanye because he's a
crazy person and he might turn on us
yeah that's fine
but we can take that popular culture I
don't love rap music I don't love
hip-hop surprise surprise but you what
you can take the little hold you can and
transform it and build it does that mean
Kanye West is gonna button up and become
an Edmund Burke conservative I'm not
putting money on it but we can take what
we have of that popular culture Kanye
West wants to be an independent thinker
a free thinker be able to have his own
say and protect his own liberties maybe
cardi B wants to keep a little bit more
of her money I don't blame her she makes
a lot of money we take that and we can
we can use that we can transform that we
can use that to build upon and that
that's the American spirit
but Mayday the International Workers day
wants to tear down tear down the
hierarchies tear down class structures
tear down civilization and what America
does is build it all up and make America
great again that's that's a good way to
celebrate all right that is our show I
will see you all tomorrow get your
mailbag questions in for Thursday in the
meantime I am Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Dahl show I'll see you then
the Michael Knoll show is a daily wire
forward publishing production executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey supervising producer Mathis
Glover our technical producer is austin
stevens edited by alex Zingaro audio is
mixed by mike core amina hair and makeup
is by Jeshua
of era copyright for word publishing
2018